[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
reach out to the into the group chat
live in the bleacher report app
presented by
fanduel it's a beautiful thursday and
one of us in the group chat
was invited to a sick day party
yesterday but she declined
because she may not have been sober for
today's show
my name is cabbie richards in the middle
is our betting expert and on everybody's
vip list
that's kelly stewart and greatness comes
in threes the goat
gronk and g-money greg ivory uh each
week in our chuck versus america segment
you guys pick the prop bet and we go
head-to-head with the iconic
charles barkley last week we all voted
that steph curry would outscore luka
doncic in their head-to-head matchup
it was box office and the game was a bit
of a blowout
but the matchup was a lot closer than
expected take a look at who chuck
broadway
how about this chuck versus america who
scores more tonight
cool hand luca or stefan can i see it
america's undefeated uh three i'm gonna
go with steph curry in this one
i'm gonna go with steph curry he got a
lot of dog got to carry a lot of dead
weight
america undefeated chuck
three and four
you tell them ernie america is
undefeated we are 8-0 and chuck
made the right decision he decided to
ride with us let's take a look at the
standings
because we are 8-0 and chuck since he
rode with us to go with steph curry he
improves
to and four but we are still
uncomfortable
four games ahead of the iconic charles
barkley
look the effort and skill demonstrated
by two-way wigs
has andrew wiggins has our dude greg
ivory elevated on some good vibes
cabbie i told you last week we called
him two-way wig
confirmed it with you on twitter this
week we
call him two-way wigs out here but uh
let me get to uh what i'm here to do let
me give out some hoodies
i'm in the comments uh i got
zay 4x he got john wall he's rocking
with john wall he's in the rockets
tonight shout out to you and your take
he's walking away with a hoodie i see
enderman enderman's back shouts out to
you enderman he's also walking with the
rockets and john wall a striped
giraffe stripe giraffe 45 says he's
walking with the heat tonight
sam deans rocking with the heat cabbie
everybody that i said is walking away
with a hoodie i just wanted to make sure
that they knew that
but uh let's get this show on the road
all right put the handy dandy down let's
get this show on the road
it sounds like the audience is on either
side tonight we're gonna get to it in
our chuck
versus america bet you know we um
we asked you guys on social which team
will be the first to 10 points tonight
the teddy is back baby the miami heat
or the houston rockets the heat are
cooking recently winning three games in
a row
and right now according to the twitter
poll the miami heat
has 61 of the vote that
it will score 10 points first in
tonight's action
against the houston rockets uh g-money
this sounds like
it's a reason for celebration and good
vibes
of course cabbie of course it's time for
celebration and good vibes you know i
love this bet
we invented the phrase tinny here
we did invented this yeah yes kelly we
invented that
g-money wasn't it tenny and henny or
something like that
it's where it started and now it's you
know we're just rocking with the teeny
the race to 10. uh i love this bet uh
but i need the people in the comments i
need people in the comments to let me
know who are you riding with who are you
riding with is it
the miami heat is it the houston rockets
kelly you know value
do you see any here so in case you guys
missed the little math lesson on our
ig page the other day you should never
lay -115 for a coin flip
and now everybody wants lane minus 122
for a coin flip that is exactly what
this is
i know the houston rockets aren't that
great but this or
this this bet is who's going to get the
10 points first it's out of the gate it
is quick
it is fast paced and even the worst
teams can keep
up for the first two or three minutes we
see it all the time
minus 104 kind of acceptable for a coin
put minus 122 are you out of your mind
so you're going with the houston rockets
then
yeah i have to go to houston rockets uh
look bottom line
i understand i need miami to win tonight
but that's beside the point houston's
first attend
okay i because i love pj tucker's shoe
game and he always has
sick kobe exclusives the colorways the
pro tros the player editions
pj tucker from the corner demarcus
cousins with the three
jay shantay john wall boom that's 10
points right there
so i'm going with the houston rockets at
minus 104
on federal don't let me down fellas
let's get it the tinny
g money cabbie i am uh
i'm in the comments and and and i'm
seeing a lot of
houston rockets so i'm not giving out
any hoodies there because
emojis yeah i'm seeing a lot of houston
rocket emojis but uh
i'm not giving out hoodies because i i
feel a certain way about this
wait whoa this is not good vibes great
are your feelings into it like what's
going on here
i i i feel like i just feel a certain
way about this i like the miami heat
tonight
uh first they have a guy by the name of
duncan robinson on their team who
has the burner he has the burner coming
off those like a burner account
no kelly can i borrow it no not a burner
account
he has the burner from three uh they
also got my guy bam out of bio over
there uh they got jimmy butler they got
dogs cabbie you know how i feel about my
dogs
they're minus 122 for a reason so uh
i'm rocking with the miami heat here
well listen they are they are cooking
with a three-game win streak that's nice
so
america tune in to inside the nba's
pre-game show
to see how chuck is riding it looks like
listen we got to rock with the the
twitter poll so 61
on the miami heat g-money represents the
people kelly and i will ride with the
people
so we're going with the miami heat make
sure to lock in on fanduel you can get
the link
on br socials for the tenney actually no
the 10 of you could just bet straight up
on fanduel so shout out to our our
partners over there
don't forget to send us our videos if it
hits and gmoney and
apparently mikey locks will be in the
mix celebrating if that's any hits so
send us your videos because we'd love to
feature them on our show
the other most fun bet to bet in america
is the 3x2
and we invented that one as well so
you're welcome america
quite simply it is will two
three-pointers be made
in the first three minutes of the game
last week we've been on dallas and
golden state we were there with the
popcorn ready for
the explosiveness luca and steph curry
unfortunately only steph curry hit a
three we the three by two did not hit so
our record drops
to seven and three so we're back at it
tonight
philly at portland 10 30 game we have
logo lillard it's game time and the uh
legitimate splash brother seth curry
in the mix we are rocking with the 3x2
g-money tap in with your army army
cabbie kelly i need everybody whether
you're on youtube
or if you're listening on the app uh
i need everybody to just comment yes
just comment yes because we are writing
we are writing and we are writing
uh the three by two uh kelly
are you riding the three by two i know
last week you were writing we didn't win
are you
still riding i'm a little salty about
that greg i'm not gonna lie but then i
started looking at this total sitting at
229 and a half it's gonna be in the 230s
by tip because it's a late game and you
know none of these fools
are gonna bet the under so that one's
gonna keep going up
beside the point in a high scoring game
that means they got to get it out of the
gate
i do think we will see two threes right
out of the gate first minute 30
first minute 145 we may have to sweat it
for a second but i think we get there
and we get the cash when kelly mentions
fools she's talking to people like me
i'm actually going to be on the other
side just i'm like
51 no today only because
with the philadelphia 76ers everything
goes with the big man everything goes
through joel embiid
and he's great inside and out but his
perimeter game
isn't the strongest part of his game
even though he's versatile so
big man in the paint maybe danny green
hits a three maybe seth curry does
but um i'm gonna i'm leaning no
for this particular one unless hey
listen if robert covington
and dame lillard go off then it cashes
g-money celebrates
i'm still leaning though today uh bad
vibes
i know fat spots that's uh flag being
thrown
i'm giving away some hoodies why not
spitters are quitters
uh shout out to you you're walking away
with me
you're handling um a teeth is the goat
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh
caviar i'll give my take here um
we i mean we have to ride with yes
we have to ride with yes simply because
me and mikey lotta is going to be
on br's betting instagram live
writing the yes and you guys have to
make sure you guys are tapped in
tune in uh and bring good vibes bring
ring sunsets why not bring the sunset
apart
also check out br betting social on
twitter
and instagram for the link to the 3x2 on
fanduel
and as always if it hits send us your
videos
look in 26 games he's outscored his
older brother
lonzo ball and he's a rookie and he's 19
years old and he doesn't even start
lamella ball is a staple on bleach
report
he lit up basketball twitter on monday
when he dropped seven
threes against the houston rockets this
dude is running away
with the rookie of the year campaign i
mean
my this dude is like there are other
people
in in contention and you know i suppose
we should take a look at the other
young talented ballers that are in
contention but lamela ball right now
i think on fanduel let's see it here
he's a minus 350.
tyrese halliburton from the sacramento
kings plus 600
emanuel quickly from the next plus 16 uh
100 james weisman from the warriors plus
1600's but lamelo balogi money
he's just killing it right now so
my question to you is cap or no cap
lamella ball rookie of the year
snow cap kevin no i'll just i'll just
yeah i'll just
tell everybody to just say no cap in the
comments uh
because uh it's no cap that lamelo ball
will be walking away with the ripping of
the year
uh i'll i i like james weisman early
cabbie i like james weisman early
you know he was he got off to a good
start uh
then we moved him over to the second
unit and then you know he got adjusted
in the second unit but now he's just
he just went down to an injury and
lamelo has just taken off as you just
said so uh
it's no cap for me but i need everybody
to get in the comments and just comment
no cap kelly what are you thinking who
are you rocking with
well if we're just looking at the
pricing right let's just say i've never
watched any of these guys play
what the math tells you here is that the
bookmakers
priced lamello a little higher than he
should be we just saw the tweet he was
minus 280.
he dropped seven threes on monday they
moved him to minus 350.
that's a big money move not necessarily
based on bets but
past performance my big thing here is
now
they don't want any more lamellar money
right now they're just sitting tight
hanging out so they're trying to entice
money in other areas don't take the bait
lamello is winning rookie of the year
you know what kelly i'm one of these
fools that i'm gonna take the bait
because i saw plus 600 tyrese
halliburton with
the sacramento kings and he's nice my
guy is shooting 45
from three-point range and his team is
in playoff contention most importantly
they're 12 and 11
and if halliburton can help them get
into the playoff race
in the western conference not just the
playing game but the actual a seven
and eight seed or a seventh seed that's
gotta bode well for his rookie of the
year chances so
i'm after the show i'm probably going to
go on facebook
the it's the plus 600 cals because my
eyes are like this
and if he can i'm trying to talk myself
into it
and you know what i just need to listen
to you more often but for right now
i think tyreese halliburton has a chance
how is the audience taking this one i'm
in the comments and uh
i see a lot of lamello in the comments i
see a lot of lamello
uh mellow ballin no cap melo
for rookie of the year uh super vibing
with lamella
yeah in the comments they're just
rocking with lamello uh
cabbie let me let me i don't dislike
your take
holly burton actually plays up the road
for me uh in sacramento
and he has been bawling this year
averaging 12. you mentioned
shooting over 45 from three uh so his
numbers
aren't too far off from lamelo but what
lamelo has
is he has social media behind him
bleacher report
us we're talking about him every other
day you know
he has different outlets talking about
him on social media that's just
pumping up his hype and i think with
that being said
that's going to push him over the top to
win this rookie of the year
well last week in a much hyped matchup
between two
mvp candidates lebron james and nicola
yokic
there was no load management to be seen
both guys played 35 minutes
where we do need some load management
greg ivory
is in your ability to correctly pick a
five leg
single game parlay yo lebron came
through for you last week you hit two of
the five but jokic
it's like he took a night off and then
he dropped a 50 piece
the next day against the sacramento
kings
so far greg just as a recap
you're 0-6 my dude you're about as
effective as a draymond green half-court
shot
so let's roll into philly versus
portland tonight
it's a 10 30 game you have another
chance at redeeming
your bet with kelly stewart which is
again for the audience a
500 bet that you'll hit one of these
five-legged
single-game parlays g-money i'm sorry i
had to do that too we should actually
take a look at last week's ticket have
we looked at the ticket yet
let's pull it up pull it up yeah there
it is see those x's right there yeah
yeah i see it
yep you see him all right we can come
back
let's go we'll get this on the road here
we go
uh first leg of the parlay we're going
to go with joel
and b to score over 20 points today i'm
just going to make this one snappy i
need the guys in the control room to be
ready because we're just going to get
this one over
and beat over 10 and a half rebounds
that's the next one we're gonna go
moving along to my guy dame lillard to
score
over 25 points seth curry to score
over 10 points this is looking pretty
good
we're gonna round it off we're gonna
round it off with my guy ben
simmons to go over seven and a half
assists
yes lock it in please lock it in yes
and you know what this one might hit
greg this
like everything looks pretty good and
and ben simmons averages
eight assists per game so that's seven
and a half so
he just has to play to his average and
that one hits but that's what's
that's the only part of this parlay greg
that's a little bit shaky for me is the
ben simmons
assist prop i want to see the ticket
i'm just trying to win a bet yeah i know
you are and i i think if you
i want to see the ticket can somebody
put the ticket up because i'm pretty
sure this might be
in yeah what i knew it i was like
there's no way
dame only 25 points i knew something was
if you roll the tape back week two i
said no no no
none of this nonsense it's gotta be like
15 to one or better
no no you never to one and you're still
not gonna hit it greg that's the fun
part here
kelly kelly did you do any research
before you made the bet with greg
research no i said week two i was like
there's got to be some accountability
here
you can't just be like throwing out
minus 450 parlays
i just i just want you to i just want
you to review the terms of our bet kelly
if [ __ ] yeah if
all right listen listen if i hit a five
leg parlay this season you owe me 500
is that correct i like i said
when you try to give some 12 to one
nonsense week two i said no no
no there needs to be some terms and
conditions here
i'm gonna have them pull the tape we'll
review it next week best of luck to you
let me tell you this right now ben
simmons is still not going over seven
and a half assists
okay though it's okay though to only
score like 19.
that's what that's called karma greg i
can't wait till seth curry
scores over 10 points because of course
he's a splash brother he's totally going
that was minus 2 000 and that's a lock
yes i can't i can't wait for tonight
either thank you so much for tapping
into the group chat presented by fanduel
remember what you learned here today
always read the terms and conditions on
bets with your friends
if you are blood related to steph curry
you are a splash brother and finally
if you bet with america we are going to
continue to be undefeated
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
my name is cabby richards and we are
leaving the group chat
[Music]
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you